wow
it's a guard goose
it's a domestic goose that's utilized as
a guard animal
ooh
if i ever moved to like a a farm
maybe i'll
invest in a guard goose oh jerome gambit
do i play jerome in this tournament
i also be against the right player
uh
if i get a chance maybe i will
just for the lulls
um
okay i'll play e4 i'll desert two
if i play someone a thousand points
lower rated i berserk and i played
jerome
what is jerome again
it's this and this right
oh we have a jerome wow good timing
so the point is i win stuff back kind of
i'm not supposed to win stuff back but
uh wow i won in eight moves with the
jerome what the starch of the stream
[Music]
i was going to take more stuff
i just want to show this computer graph
so i was losing
but because i played the jerome
good things happened to me
also thanks for the raid fm john curtis
chess
if you're just joining i played my first
game of the tournament
jerome gambit
and i won in eight moves
i sacked two pieces but i won the two
pieces back
and i would have been up two ponds
or almost six pawns according to
stockfish
okay back to tournament
uh welcome everyone
so maybe i'll keep a notepad document 30
months whoa
high hole
keep it going
it's a lot of months
almost three years
okay i did this last time where
uh i keep track of the gamuts i play
so we have one is jerome
um two i mean we gotta get a stafford uh
sacrifice line with bc5 after x4 oh
remind me after this tournament i'll try
and address that
or maybe i can address it during the
tournament if i get that line
okay so stafford gamut time
um
yeah i gotta at least have one staffer
in this tournament
thank you pie hole and lockheed
and zwerga cook or zwergasak
so if king d2 there's a funny line
knight takes h2 rook h2 queen e5
winning a rook
i think it still works here
except in this line rook takes h2 knight
or bishop g4 winning a queen
so
yeah white's gonna be less incentivized
to wow i wanted nine moves
uh
people are so generous
i was actually gonna say that it
shouldn't be so bad after queen f4
uh
yeah queen f4
it still takes work i guess queen h5 is
kind of awkward to play
but
a little bit better for black
i guess white was terrified of my
tactics
okay so i have a stafford in jerome
um
nine move win
eight move win
maybe i'll just try and beat people as
quickly as possible
these are my favorite streams oh those
are my favorite bits
thank you bitcoin boy
okay gotta play in england because why
not
um never played this opponent before
let's play one of these
ah they didn't own passant wow wow
wow wow wow that stafford was nasty wow
oh thank you
your wows were nasty
okay so we have like in england i'm down
a pond but
so far good things have been happening
to me
so we'll try and keep it up if h3 i play
h5
and we'll uh we'll gamble the bishop
maybe
i just want to take back and win
everything
and if the pattern continues i'll win
this game and one more move
if i had eight move win nine move win
this is move ten
opponent needs to resign now
i think it's already winning for bach
though
or is it i don't know
um now it should be
although it's complicated
hey eric hype train hype so time for
prime subbing everyone let's go i'm
rosen let's go in rows and let's go him
rose and let's go bamanos
thank you amazing anch
so i kind of want to play this move to
threaten queen g3
but this is more civilized
rookie one king f8
and then queen h4 to g3 will be coming
uh there's 94
i'm also calculating this line bishop f2
king f2 queen h4
oh that looks kind of fun
e3
yeah i think i win the queen in the end
actually
i'm gonna force the king to the d-file
and then i'll skewer
and win enough material
if the king goes back i made in two
another nice line
thank you concupiscence gifting five
yeah i appreciate all the hype oh did i
miscalculate
i think i may have
yeah i just missed bishop e3
oh no i'm losing kind of
although it shouldn't be too bad i mean
queen g5
i'm only down at night
of this idea too
there's some initiative queen d3i bishop
five
i really want to play this move
ah there's a funny line
it doesn't work though
played in my first otb tournament today
got five eighths lol
five fourths
that's one point
two five
wait oh 0.5 out of 4 oh that's
um that's still more than zero
i have this this move
i think i'll play this move
lift rooks gets wool
so if takes uh i
win in pin
uh if this
i just want to pressure everything
um this is a pin
i think i'll play this to threaten the
the battery
yeah
the bishop's useful here preventing rook
f1
although i guess i would take anyway
so bishop d2 is expected
i gotta move quicker too
wow
[Music]
put this back on the target c2
i might as well push my pawn
pawn is close to queening
still down on time
the position is interesting though
okay white's taking a lot of time here
uh
play this move
workout before i have queen here check
i think i might be losing in that line
but
it's part of life
i have this no that doesn't work
i have this move
bishop here i play queen e2
oh it's tactics
good move
okay i gotta weather this storm
18 seconds
oh no i'm losing
oh g6 was such a bad move too thank you
high hole
alleviating the pain
[Music]
okay there goes my
my hope of a perfect score
oh i really like the position too i went
a little bit too crazy that game
okay no time for actually time for
tilting
i'll play one of these uh wing gambit
things
oh and thank you gary gifting to the
jungle students
okay so this is a line that i saw on
twitter the other day
there was like a lila stockfish game
that went into
something like this
it's like a wing gambit but kind of
inspired my danish gambit
where we have the two bishops
very quick development
probably want to go for e5 at some point
maybe right away
but maybe not
let's keep developing
[Music]
so i have all my minor pieces developed
and now d1
yeah very soon e5 is coming
now queen g5 hitting the queen
probably want to go for this move
just had to watch out for the
diagonal pressure
now f4 looks nice
i can also
no that would blunder a queen
i could take on f7 actually
wow
so takes and then takes
or if takes a knight i win the queen
and i'll win probably the e pawn
although
i think i'll keep the pressure because
i'd rather take with knight
and keep my bishop here
okay so i'm just realizing i berserk
this game i have 32 seconds
but
let's try and uh
play quicker
it is equal material
[Music]
oh no i just wondered
when it misses it
wait to the point blender
no there's rookie one
[Music]
yeah so it's kind of a fair trade
um i have slightly more activity
target the g7 pawn
put the rook far away
i think i want to create this
construction with pawn on f4
i'll bring the king in
g4
maybe like h3f4
my moves here i mate
um
gradually making progress
yeah i want to play this and this
15 seconds
should be enough time
again i here i mate
f5 is incoming
actually let's play this first
put the bishop on e5
may have been a small mistake
oh there's a funny mate
can your take can hear a mate
or if king here i win the thing
okay let's make next move
okay
i have to keep on my documents
uh
game three was england gambit
game four is weird wing
gambit scene on twitter
so these have been my game so far
nice final mate
okay thank you cornstalk defense subbing
with prime thank you lucky
well the goal is to win the tournament
but the goal is just to win games as
quickly as possible
with gambits
um
[Music]
i think i'll go for a black mardemer
yeah
the black mardemer
you can get black mardima from scandi
but this is another way to get it
where the point is i've opened that file
i get some quick development
i'll bring my queen
in bring the bishop in
[Music]
um
[Music]
yeah let's keep the bishop here
whoa it's half loaf gifting 10 thank you
half loaf
really appreciate that
okay so i'm down the pawn here
didn't berserk this game so
i do have time to work with
uh first thing that comes to mind is
take some takes
but then there's
there's some weird lines here
uh takes takes takes i lose e3 with
check
you can also just take in bishop d4
hitting the queen
there's this move bishop c5
very pleasant position though
it's the type of position where it's
easy for back to blender
yeah that's a good move
so i'll just take and play king h1
and now i want to take on f6 and mate
so that's a move now i just want to take
here and win the knight
because there's a pin
oh
[Music]
do you have this move there's f5
i think i'll just play h3 here
and see where the knight is going live
stream
hey good catch
eq triple snake
yeah thanks again half loaf saying thank
you for the wonderful entertainment
yeah we'll try and have a mix of
entertainment and education
i don't think black is too entertained
from what's going on here though the
queen's hit and the queen's tied down to
the thing the knights
and there's really no safe squares where
the queen can still defend the knight
bishop d3
uh looking for a quick win
i think i'll just bring the rook in
i want to take and lift the rook and
then queen h5
there's f6 in the end
um
okay let's do this anyway
at the very least i have uh this move
and this just wins a rook
oh let's do this and then i might move
back
if if black plays g6
wow
check
okay let's just do this in 94.
i could have taken the rook and been off
the exchange but uh
this looks more
more winning
okay the queen defends from a distance
we have knight t6 or knight g5
let's start with this
okay so now i'm threading the pawn
because the queen is obstructed also
threatening potentially to take in rook
d7
or maybe even this move
black's resisting though
expecting this and then
okay i want to lift another rook over
there we go oh that's meat
i thought it was just a strong check but
i guess that's meat okay
um
so that was a black mardemer
okay it's time for a walrus
walrus time
oh walrus gambit declined
i'll still play in aggressive fashion
interesting
i'm not down any material though
okay i'm gathering this pawn
let's go thank you crooksteezy
b5
trying to gain space on all areas of the
board
wow
takes
there's a funny line uh takes rook p8
queen here i win the queen
let's go
thank you techno die in the store for
the the dollar
yeah white's going to play on
run slightly down on time
[Music]
getting out of the pin
i'm okay with the double pawns
it's basically a queen for bishop
i'll take this
going after this pawn
i might just go after f2
the tenderest of pawns
that may have been a mouse slip but no
mercy
okay that was nice
so that was a walrus
declined
okay what gambit next
let's play a vampire e5 and then f4
or whatever this is
i just have to make up gambits at this
point
uh okay so i'm down the pawn
this is like an english wing gambit
uh i'm envisioning this
this and mate
might be hard to achieve but let's try
or like this and this
okay so there's a pin i'm threatening
made in one please play this has anyone
ever recognized you in real life and
said hey
it's my dream to do that
oh so uh just a few hours ago i was
playing tennis
and the people at like two quarts over
one of them recognized me
and said
something like
oh you're eric rosen and then they said
that they like my gambit videos
so i'm kind of doing a gambit stream in
honor of the person who recognized me
earlier
um but yeah it's been happening more
lately
like coming back from
russia i was in line in like chicago
customs
and i got recognized by like three
different people
um
just like standing in line they were on
like completely different flights
am i winning here
light moves i have knight c7
okay so i'll win this thing it's
actually going to get really spicy after
bishop here came here
and g7 might hang
okay i'm gonna yeah make space for the
king on f1
actually yesterday i was having dinner
or uh having like a late lunch
like outdoor seating not too far away
from the st louis chess club
i was at the table with like
three other or three grand masters
and then someone like passed by and said
oh you're that chess guy
and they didn't recognize the people who
i was eating with all of whom were
higher rated than me
but
yeah just an avid youtube watcher
is pretty cool
[Music]
okay so queen b1 i'll play this move
i'm up a rook wait no i have a rook for
knight in three pawns
oh hello dr jay birdmd
oh which gm's uh two of the chess weebs
and ray robson
so
yeah it's been flattering um sometimes
i'm not sure like how to react but
it's humbling
okay let's uh
maybe trade queens
i want to attack on the king side still
also up a lot of time here
okay we'll support the pawn
this is reminiscent of london system
it's just half of a london system
like half of a loaf
stafford gambit for life yeah welcome
back dante boom shanka
i already played the stafford but maybe
i'll have another stafford at some point
okay trying to make progress
um
[Music]
where's my
i'll just move back and move the h-pawn
up
i have to be careful of knight to check
okay so take with bishop
now march the h pawn
king is reasonably safe here
i'm just realizing i'm playing the
person in second place
so it's kind of a key game
i didn't calculate this i assume it's
okay
oh no my bishop
okay i'm gonna win on time
i want to play this in this
okay so that was uh
let's see what leach has calls this
actually
[Music]
oh english opening wing gambit okay
it's not the most surprising name
english
go back to tournament
i'm tracking all my
openings this tournament
english opening wing
hammocks
oh dark 4001 from indonesia in first
with some catching up to do
oh the winglish oh i like that name
okay
english
whoever said that first good job
okay i'm gonna play whatever this is
g5
we can get some g5 emotes the idea is
just to get initiative against the
knight
control the center with the pawns
uh
i guess i mean this is kind of
reminiscent of halloween
just keep advancing
i'm probably gonna regret this at some
point but it looks fun
it's almost trapped has to go back to e2
so far i've just moved pawns this game
at some point i should develop my pieces
uh
keep moving pawns
sometimes the pieces they're
a bit too heavy to lift
you just have to warm up by pushing
pawns
okay
move my first first piece first non-pawn
thing
on move 13 with my king
i have this move knight c1 e4
pawns are doing work
what is this opening
i have so much like room to breathe too
i feel like this is a good opening for
someone who's
maybe claustrophobic
because i'm not at all cramped
if anything i have too much like
air around me
uh i should develop a knight
yeah i wanted to play a4 but
beginning to feel slightly blockaded
at this point i just developed my my
minor pieces
um i'm okay with trading queens
when i bring the knight in there's no
way for white to defend the pawn
and then white's going to have to worry
about knight c2 coming
that looks kind of like a 960 position
white still can potentially castle
either way
although the bishop's kind of stuck
the knights are kind of stuck too
um knight c5
what to do
[Music]
let's start with this move
i know let's start with this move
i could take
i think i'll play game g7
under the f8 square for the rook
i'm really greedy i'll take the pawn
although let's defend let's defend
everything
so my idea is to play this and do things
on c2
if g3 i have e3 which is nice
if g3 now i have h3 or even knight f3
yeah i'm just trying to squeeze
kind of squeeze from both sides
um
am i mating in that line
oh there's a funny mate
so king e3 rook takes e5
oh it's not quite mate though
i was thinking knight c2 would be force
mates
um wait is it meaning
back there
no it's not quite mating
okay i'll play this
we're actually simplifying a lot
it has to take
bishop is going to develop to one of
these squares
and then i'll take and play bishop b1
and then push the pawn
oh i'm throwing to queen now
oh that's kind of funny ah
wait stops it
wait can i check take here and then push
here here
no it doesn't work
i'll start with this
there's a really funny line
so the line is uh
oh i think it works too rook f1 look at
this line
oh no my rook if the rook takes like
queen with check if bishop takes
i promote with no no no no
i played the wrong pawn move but it's
okay
i think a2 was still winning
a2 was still winning
i got way too excited there
okay now i clean the this is what i
wanted earlier
it's almost meat
okay king d4 queen b2 would be a nice
mate
uh that was a weird game
uh what was this game
well rook f1 was actually really nice
it's top move
one of the top moves
uh
so thankfully a2 was still winning i
should have just queen immediately
uh someone says i missed knight i missed
maiden one
like pc2
knight bc2
i'm not sure if
i might be getting like
mate rolled rook rolled
[Music]
not seeing force made here oh maybe
earlier
or later
okay
yeah maybe some missed opportunities
there that was a fun game
what opening was that
he chest calls it the
earthstrom gambit
sound like scandinavian fish
very strong
okay
playing for ruku
let's go for a budapest
ah what is this
uh i can't really play budapest i could
play
what is this okay let's make up a gambit
here
e5
the smiley face gambit
against the stonewall
and now
wait this just looks bad though
okay i guess i'm gambling upon
so it takes uh i'll get some weird
initiative
okay
smiley face gambit versus stonewall
so i actually went back the pawn
i'm left with
slightly better structure i don't have
casting rights but should be okay
right here i'll play a6
yeah this is actually turning very
positional
the problem for white is this pawn i'm
going to play this and potentially f5
later
like even if white doubles up
at some point i'm going to have f5
b4 is a good try
might as well take in bishop c6
and the pawn is a goner i have this move
too
yeah when you see a good move look for a
better move
okay so at this point i just want to
trade rooks and simplify
so this force is a trade after this is
this ivor d8
and then i'll clean up the pawns
i might even uh yeah just sack and
show the winning technique
so i can make another passer like this
so it's not stalemate because white has
one pawn move
okay that was nice
hey first place let's go
okay that was a cool gambit too
let's have to make things up when the
opponent
doesn't let me do my
i plan a gambits
okay so less than 20 minutes left still
a lot of people chasing my tail
play e4
maybe king's gambit
try and go for some og gambits
uh
what's a gamut against the pierce
i think g4 at some point
or maybe i'll play uh h4h5
and gambit my
white block stopping me from
doing things
okay i think i'll go for an earlier g4
i'm gaming my development
uh h5 i guess
i'm still trying to play in the style of
like winning as quickly as possible
[Music]
oh thank you kelp subbing with prime
so the pawns well supported
going for h6 very soon
was probably a reasonable strategy
against a pierce player
or black was just trying to go for a
solid setup
and i've disturbed it as much as
possible
although now i'm probably losing a pawn
yeah i can't actually defend everything
so i'll gambit b2
yeah this pawn is chilling very nicely
um
might as well complete development
it's not easy for bach to
complete the queenside development
what to do maybe this move
maybe this move
[Music]
okay um this pawns in some small amount
of danger
i kind of want to play this
to do or h7
play h7
are people trying to roll me again i
think they are
yeah chat's going crazy about a free
rook
there is no miss free rook unless there
was
but i'm not tricked so easily anymore
oh my pawn
ah my beloved hairy h-pawn
so if blackjack's with knight i have
rook h5
sticks with rook
i guess we trade
oh
[Music]
well the pawn survives
for another turn
i have this move
this almost traps a queen queen here i i
discover attack
um all the squares along the rank were
controlled
okay now i want to play e5
which probably doesn't quite work here
oh black plays e5
okay let's put the knight back
where it belongs
did i actually blunder a rook
wait now i'm curious
where was it
oh i blundered a rook ah i blundered a
rook
ah i saw my knight was attacked i didn't
trust chat
i thought chad all like simultaneously
decided to troll me
okay i guess i need to have some more
trust in chat
thankfully this is kind of paying off
oh
or is it
takes takes
going on here
take the
the knight
that's my rook though
[Music]
okay i'm just taking king d2 i guess
i have an idea a queen g8
also i'm preventing rook c8
is kind of important here
calculating bishop here here here takes
takes
here i think it's okay
now i'll be threatening takes and
fun stuff in the end
okay
hey it's oh it's not me oh it's me okay
i saw this uh it's almost made but it's
not legal but this was mate okay oh this
was also made
okay let's go
still in first place
tied with dark four thousand one
uh what opening was that
um
here it's weird or pure it's weird
gambit i'll call it
yeah it was another kind of inventive
opening
okay 12 minutes left playing something
something something
okay berserking
and let's play
the bononi gambit
oh let's play against the smith mooring
gambit
but white's not gambiting
so let's scan it g5
and g4
oh i gotta on poisson i guess
what is this opening
okay let's just go for some other main i
guess
uh
oh no i'm getting forked in the end
knight c7
okay white saw the mating threat
i think i still play king d8
i could also try and be clever
okay let's gamble the rook
it's a spirit of oh oh no my queen
i'm losing a queen here
i'm losing a queen here
i kind of backfired
i'll have a a rookie night for it
i'm down on time
it's not so bad
it's kind of bad
just have to weather the storm
ooh
it's running made in one now
okay that worked out well
what was that opening
what does lee just call it
this oh the smithmore gambit of course
okay smith
mora
on wild
okay
that was a weird game
about 10 minutes left
yeah that featured like a semi beautiful
gambits i mean i got some material for
the queen
oh i'm playing uh
yeah my arch nemesis
um
i still want to play like an og gambit
i'll play the smith mora how about
okay smithmore gambit time
i have to make mark asterman proud
actually don't know so much theory i'm
gonna try and play like a grand prix
style setup
ooh
and queen d4 looks attractive
also f5 let's just sack stuff
the goal is sack sack mate
main point i want to open this uh
diagonal
this is actually a principled move when
black's a bit underdeveloped
i could sack my bishop
let's attack my bishop
oh it looks kind of fun
because i fork and then i have this move
i also have queen d5 wow
i also have this move
so many moves to choose from
i guess i'll play queen d5
there should be six uh
and this should be force mates
how does blackstock work f7
okay now um i feel like i'm just playing
with my food
there's this move
which is discover check
okay that was a nice game
oh smith mora oh mark asserman is proud
smith
mora against my
biggest rival
okay
thank you qazi sly
so eight minutes left probably time for
what like three or four more games
at this rate
so i did have that one loss i think i'm
up rating this tournament
uh okay we'll play another wing gambit
okay wing gambit meets the king's gambit
what is this position
oh this looks kind of fun
so it's like a normal king's gambit with
c5 and b4 thrown in
so i just have to
merge that the ideas
okay i'm losing this pawn
uh i might as well take now now it
reminds me of an evans gambit
the pawn on b4
but still ideas of kings gambit
so i guess i'll play this in d4
kind of this move
i have to be a little bit careful here
time wise
[Music]
too this pawn is tender
let's play e5 first
so if not here i think i play bishop d5
or maybe i i take
okay this move makes me happy
if i'm down a pawn but it doesn't feel
like it because i have a massive center
with the king on f1 maybe g4 coming
actually threatening to trap the knights
yeah the knight has no squares
oh d5 is a good move though
a counter attack
well played
i guess i take and
[Music]
okay let's play bishop e3
yeah it's still a fight
i'm actually probably objectively worse
here
but it's still kind of a cool position
because i don't have the light squared
bishop
yeah black wants to play bishop h4
i think i just taken rook g3
and bring the queen in maybe bring the
knight in even
i have to watch out for my h-pawn wow
good move
okay so now here i just have to sack
right here takes takes i think it's okay
if rook c2 i can take it
i think
so i'm down the exchange down a ton of
time too
[Music]
but i have still my nice pawn center
uh good move
that's a really good move
yeah i'm under pressure here
i want to play this
not winning material but
got some initiative
draw
i want to draw though
ooh
neither does my opponent
if takes i have to take with knight
otherwise rook c2
this is terrifying now
i'm in big trouble
[Music]
it's still nice
i was really thinking black wasn't
stalemately with g3 there
but okay found another stalemate let's
go
on the verge of flagging
stalemate pog
let's go
so that was uh
that was uh what opening was that
wing gambit
kings gambit
evans gambit
it's like some
combination of a lot of different
flavors
okay playing for ruku
let's play oh let's play the hillbilly
that's a fun gambit
this will probably be the last game
imrozen stalemate
yeah it's not the complete tournament
without like one dirty stalemate trap
okay so i'm down upon
but i have the file
have a nice queen
that's a little bit uh passive
oh thank you i'll hush me
the five dollars towards the sub i
appreciate that
if i play this there's uh
some e5 move
i think i'll play queen
f2 eventually i want to go for d4
okay
i'm gonna try and start migrating pieces
to the king side
here we go
so i want to play c4 bishop c2
[Music]
just get as many attackers as possible
if takes i take with knight and knight
f6 i guess i take
ooh so here i can take this
calculating takes takes takes takes
takes it's okay
and the goal is to remove the knight
i guess i'm not immediately threatening
to take
there is a
queen so now it's just more positional
and doesn't look like this game will
count for the tournament
but
i think i'm
pretty safe
with the current standing
king safety first
okay pressure the knight
there's a line uh never mind
i'll put the knight on g6
and probably look to put the other
knight in e5
oh there's this move
okay i might as well just finish with
sacking everything
now threatening made in one
yeah there's some fun mates here
um
yeah like this
i mean i fade here here so it's discover
check
and after rook c2
which is only legal move queen g8s mate
okay that was a fun tournament
got my uh
my dose of gambits in for the day or for
the week
oh that was hillbilly
okay so played 14 games total
last one was hillbilly versus carol khan
um
if this goes on youtube let me know if
you made it this far
uh and let me know what your favorite
gamut is in the comments
or in the twitch chat
with chat
saying
things hello to possum
i love you too
oyado